this morning we are hearing from
criminal justice reform activist alice
marie johnson
about the black lives matter movement
the backlash over her participation in
the republican national convention and
if she plans to vote in the fall johnson
as you may have heard was released from
prison two years ago
when president trump commuted her life
sentence she had served almost
22 years 22 years for a non-violent
drug and money laundering crimes and
they were her first offenses
then last week the president granted her
a full pardon the day after
her very stirring speech at the
republican convention
some say you do the crime you do the
time
however that time should be fair and
just
we've all made mistakes none of us
want to be defined forever based on our
worst
decision alice marie johnson joins us
now after that speech alice good morning
it's really good to see you
good morning gail it's great to see you
again let me just say you got rave
reviews after that convention after your
speech at the rnc
what was that moment like for you it
felt so
surreal to me at first to be speaking
before the nation
about criminal justice reform and really
fulfilling the promise that i made to
the women and me and i left behind
that was a dream come true for me you
know because alex this is the thing
people felt your heart they felt your
sincerity
they felt your passion and your
commitment listen you started off by
saying
i was told that the only way i would
leave this prison was as a corpse
that is exactly what i was told i was
given a
life plus 25 year sentence without the
possibility of parole so
my situation seemed like a hopeless
situation
and i'm not alone gail there are so many
people who are just like me
who are serving draconian sentences that
don't make sense
okay so you have this high of the speech
you deliver the speech everybody says
alice marie johnson well done you leave
the speech
and then what happens to you well as i
was leaving
the um the white house there were
protesters outside of the white house
some started following me and they were
saying
really awful things it was shocking that
i was going to actually
experience that we can have a dialogue
together
but when you're screaming at me and
saying ugly things that's not
really getting the message through so as
i walked away
and they had dispersed i thought to
myself
what disrespect and
if these were my grandchildren acting
like that because these were young
people oh as young
i would be so upset to have
yeah young people acting like that but
you know i don't want to paint
all protesters with a broad brush and
say that everyone acts like that there
are there were some bad actors
but i'm putting that behind me because
we really
this criminal justice reform is my
mission
i have heard you say that you want that
to be the focus but you know how this
goes alice in the world of politics
people look at you they see you as a
woman of color
there is a lot of conversation about
donald trump's position when it comes to
the black community and some i've heard
this and i know you've heard it too
that you're being used that you're upon
uh what is she doing what do you say to
those kind of voices
i'm going to say to those voices i'm 65
years old gail
and don't no one tell me what to do i've
got my own mind i do what i want to do
and since i got my pardon papers i put
those pardon papers in my back pocket
and i'm free totally to do whatever i
want to do
i'll never forget the picture alice of
when you first got out and you got to
see your children and your grandchildren
when you came running out of the prison
i'll never forget that scene
so what's the difference for you
personally between the commutation
and then he recently gave you a full
pardon well the commutation meant that i
could rejoin my family
but i was still under the supervision
of the government i still had to report
to a probation officer
i still had trouble restrictions so now
a pardon means that i'm free
to register to vote i'm free to travel
without checking in with anyone else
i am totally free a pardon means just
that
i've got my whole life back now i want
to get your thoughts
on the black lives matter movement
because really
stories like yours is what the black
lives matter movement is about
you know the the injustice in the
criminal
system what is your take on the black
lives matter movement today
well my my take on it we i i'm as a
black woman
i also want justice i also want justice
but i also want to feel safe but at the
very core
of myself as a black woman as other
black americans we want justice we want
to be heard
that i i just hope that we can be heard
in a way
that the messaging won't be mixed up
will you be able to vote in this
election ally so this is
i i'm hoping that i will be as soon as i
go back home
i'm going to find out if i can register
to vote
and i am going to register asap
i've been waiting for this day for 20
some years to be
fully restored to to be the citizen that
i
want to be to be able to exercise my
right to vote i know it's a personal
question but will you be voting for
donald trump
you can be assured i will be voting my
country's gail
and i will suggest that everyone vote
their conscience
thank you alice marie johnson thank you
for taking the time
cheering you on always it's really good
to see you thank you
good to see you too alice marie johnson
she's one of a kind i really admire her
listen she's smart she's savvy she
admits i've made some mistakes
she has certainly more than paid the
price for that and now she's devoted her
life to helping others
and the protesters she said it was black
and white and she said but i don't care
what color they were
she thought that they were wrong and
she's reaching across the aisle she says
to work with democrats and republicans
on this issue
because she said it's not about politics
for her it's about people yeah and
people matter but there were some
landmines in those questions and she
walked through without
touching off anything she's a she's a
very elegant intelligent woman
and when you see that you just think
that sentence they gave her was insane
anthony you look at it and you think i
must be reading this wrong first offense
and she gets
when she said she was told the only way
your family will see you as a corpse
so for her she said to be walking out of
prison and to be
able to see her children grandchildren
you also see she's got a great sense of
humor she said you know gail i have
something in common with
mother teresa martin luther king and
jesus christ what is that alice
well they all have haters and i have
haters too but i'm not going to let the
haters stop me from what i'm doing
somebody's always going to criticize
also knock out vote your conscience yes
yes
good advice